ce ne sont pas des mesures de court
terme dont on a besoin bien sûr cela
peut aider mais en vérité les
agriculteur souffre depuis des années
dans un silence
incroyable je proteste depuis des années
sur les conditions qui aujourd'hui les
étouffent en fait c'est très simple d'un
côté l'Union européenne avec l'accord du
gouvernement français il faut pas faire
de l'Union européenne un bou émissaire
c'est le gouvernement français qui
approuve si des accords de libre échange
et je suis surpris d'ailleurs qu'on en
parle très peu aujourd'hui des accords
de libre échange qui avec des pays qui
ne sont pas astreint aux normes
environnementales sociales
sanitair que doivent respecter nos
agriculteurs et heureusement qu'il les
respecte d'ailleurs et puis de l'autre
côté la même Union européenne et le même
gouvernement français accable et durciss
ses normes au point même maintenant
d'interdire de cultiver 4 % de jacher
allant jusqu'à 10 % dans les prochaines
années ça veut dire qu'il y a quelque
chose d'insupportable pour nos
agriculteurs c'est que d'un côté on
ouvre les frontières à des produits qui
ne respectent pas nos normes et de
l'autre on les accap de normes
supplémentaires et pire on organise la
décroissance de la production donc ça
veut dire quoi cela veut dire que
l'Union européenne et le gouvernement
français ont décidé quelque part
consciemment de réduire la production
européenne pour importer de l'extérieur
moins cher à cou et à mauvaise qualité
environnementale c'est un suicide et les
agriculteurs n'ont pas envie de
disparaître à juste titre voilà donc
enfin il y a une réaction mais c'est pas
des petites mesurettes qui vont changer
quoi que ce soit quand vous avez un
accord avec la Nouvelle-Zélande je
prends un exemple précis déjà je crois
qu'on ne couvre que 58 % de notre
consommation de vin d'agneau et on va
importer sur 18000 km bonjour Le le coup
carbone 18000 km dans des SAES d'azote
liquide de l'agneau 30 % moins cher bah
on on tue une filière voilà donc un
moment il faut arrêter alors on réagit
pas tous de la même manière par rapport
à ce que ce que propose ou ce qu'impose
l'Union européenne notamment à travers
le Green Deal quand vous parlez de de
réduction la production là vous pensez
plus spécifiquement au Pays-Bas où le
gouvernement a décidé de réduire le
chtel d'un/ers pour le pour les pour les
beau vins en fait mais en France on
n'est pas concerné on n'est pas sur le
même Ty concerné j'ai amené il y a une
volonté en France de réduire la
production j'ai amené
j'ai apporté conditionnalité des aides
de la PAC
2023-2027 issu du règlement UE du 2
décembre 2021 et cetera faut le lire
pour le croire vous avez 9 BCAE langage
technocratique BCAE 8 maintient des
éléments du paysage jacher supérieur à 4
% des terres arables où l'exploitation
doit être consacrée et cetera ça veut
dire que là c'est pas nouveau les jacher
non c'est nouveau cette année puisque ça
avait été suspendu en 2022 et 2023 ça
s'applique cette année 2024 comment nos
agriculteurs peuvent accepter au moment
où il y a une pénurie alimentaire dans
le monde de voir une Union européenne
devenue complètement folle interdire de
cultiver vous vous rendez compte la
production agricole de céréal baisse de
10 % par rapport aux 5 dernières années
alors il y a des aspects climatiques
bien sûr mais il y a surtout qu'on
interdit à des agriculteurs de cultiver
c'est comme vous si on vous réduisit
votre émission on vous interdit de faire
votre métier
et au même moment on ouvre les vannes de
toutes les importations c'est criminel
donc finalement vraiment donc c'est
l'Union européenne c'est le gouvernement
français qui joue double jeu le
gouvernement français ment il fait
semblant de s'apitoyer enfin quand quand
on vous écoute on a l'impression que le
gouvernement français veut tuer
l'agriculture en France vous un peu fort
là quand mais'y vais pas fort il accepte
ce que fait Bruxelles l'idée du Green
Deal c'est quoi c'est de réduire la
production c'est la décroissance
agricole
alors tous les produits pas dans tous
les secteurs heureusement pas dans tous
les produitcts pour vous il faut stopper
toutes les normes écologiques pour
l'agriculture et notamment la Haus des
taxes sur le gazol non routier bien
évidemment il faut arrêter ce délire ce
délire parce que pourquoi alors on
importe des produits continue à
subventionner le mais heureusement oui
pourquoi on importe des prod il y a deux
solutions soit vous jouez sur les
importations en arrêtant d'importer des
produits à des normes environnementales
et sanitaires détestables je prends
l'exemple et je connais bien je suis
président du groupe d'amitié
France-Brésil je connais bien le Brésil
que j'aime beaucoup mais l'accord
mercosour un très très gros producteur
de pesticides ou il vient autoriser
quatre nouveaux pesticides strictement
interdit en Europe donc expliquez-moi la
logique environnmentale on précise que
l'accord Mercosur Emmanuel Macron a mis
un gros coup de
frein il y a une grande ambiguïé
d'Emmanuel Macron actuellement l'accord
Mercosur en susp attendez bon il nous
avait dit ça sur le CTA il est en
application il a toujour pas été ratifié
donc ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il
faut faut une cohérence dans la vie si
l'Union européenne dit il faut mettre
des normes supplémentaires
environnementales sur les agriculteurs
européens bah faut pas qu'au même moment
elle signe des accords avec des pays qui
aggravent et qui ont des pesticides
strictement
interdits typiquement le cas des
néonicotinoïdes où en fait ils sont
interdits et il y a il y a un certain
nombre de pays qui continuent à les
utiliser massivement et qui importent le
produit chez nous ils seront interdit en
ils seront interdit en 2026 est-ce que
c'est pas aussi un problème de cal c'est
la fausse écologie on assassine nos
agriculteurs en leur disant tu as pas le
droit tu as pas le droit tu as pas le
droit et de l'autre côté on applaudit et
on facilite les importations mais
imaginez la révolte des agriculteurs
c'est pas cohérent soit on applique des
normes à nos agriculteurs et on applique
les mêmes normes au produits importés
soit on naapplique pas on durcit pas les
normes à nos agriculteurs et on continue
d'importer mais on ne peut pas
demander le beurre l'argent du beurre et
la crémière ENF c'est insupportable pour
nos agriculteurs question politique